i also tried testosterone replacement
i tried testosterone replacement and uh
i mean it just makes you just i mean it
just
it just gives you so much virility
i mean it'll make your penis reach for a
damn deck of cards i mean it just
is so it just me i mean it just brings
your body to life
and so suddenly you're more
you know you'll just be doing nothing
and your penis will jump into your own
hand it's just more
it's not that good so i don't think i'm
gonna take it anymore
um it makes your hair thinner
you know i didn't like that i find extra
hair sitting around and i need my hair
you know i definitely like having hair
so that's really strange um
and what else about it
oh uh you also they have
it's it's injection based it's injection
based you know
and um i used to do steroids when i was
young
uh you know we used to shoot you know a
lot of people know
me and my buddy um billy conforto
r.i.p and he died and he was one of the
premier bus boys in america also
probably one of the top
i would say 40 gay prize fighters
or gay boxers fist fighters
in i would say in the 1990s
in america and uh maybe in the world i
would say in the world
top 40 homoerotic fist fighters
in i would say in first world countries
and uh i don't know second world
you get into a second world country bro
you get down there in ecuador brian a
gay dude will beat the hell out of you
bro it's nothing
that's casual that's dancing
that's dancing for them um
but what was i talking about
oh i don't even know dude
oh so yeah you also have to take this
other
drug with it they have a drug also that
um
because if you take testosterone it will
it makes your gonads they call them
gonads on the internet but really it's
your nuts
and it makes them smaller and so you
take another
drug that makes your basically makes
your gonads
regular size it's kind of like a fluffer
it's like uh you ever put a little air
in your bike tire a little
it's like that
just like that man but um
but anyway i'm just real i just don't
think it's for me so
i uh so i'm gonna quit taking it
you know i've tried it out it's been
about a month maybe six weeks
and i just don't i think the hair i
don't want to lose my hair
and
i i don't know i don't know if i notice
a lot of other benefits and stuff from
it really
um
[Music]
so and then
if you take the the secondary drug that
they have
if whenever you take that it makes your
kind of makes your nuts feel like
somebody hid something in them
it makes kind of it makes your nuts feel
like somebody just blew all their breath
like somebody just
like blew one mouth full of breath right
in
it's like you got this kind of you know
it's like you got this uh
it's like a fl it's just like somebody
just puffed your nuts up a little so i
don't like that feeling it's like you're
hot it's like somebody hit an easter egg
right in your
crotch or something in your nuts
and that makes me feel uncomfortable i
don't like that feeling it just feels
fake
so anyway so that's my experience with
it
you know when it's not um and you get it
there's different ways you can get the
testosterone replacement it's for sale
everywhere now and
so i wanted to try it out uh
and and the injection part is a little
weird like
i don't trip out on it that much because
i did it when i was young
you know to bodybuild so
it's just a low dose but it does make me
feel you know uncomfortable i feel like
um and just the upkeep of it and stuff i
just don't feel like it's for me
that's kind of the conclusion that i've
come to so
um but yeah man i think if i find a good
church i think that that
that that's a good idea you know so
i appreciate that man um
what else was i talking about you ever
done any injectable drugs riley mal
i mean unless it's for surgery um the uh
what do you call it the thing that makes
you go to sleep for surgery other than
that
no anesthesia you mean yeah that okay
that's the thing
but you never just you know you and your
buddy you know never pulled off the
interstate and done steroids or anything
like that
nope unfortunately not well
no i'm not uh i'm not uh i'm not one of
those guys i'm like you know the
calm innocent kind yeah i don't i don't
do any of those drugs i don't do any of
those like injections or whatever
um i mean you know me i'm yeah i don't
know you
but i'm learning that yeah that is not
your
vice right what would you say would you
feel like is a vice
if people say oh riley mouse say it's
your funeral okay we're at your funeral
people are like oh raleigh man man he's
a great guy
you know he uh
he was an eagle scout he was a christian
you know he
was a um
he was a karate belt he had a karate
belt
he skipped lunch sometimes he worked so
hard and what would they say but also
one of his vices was he did this what
would it be you think
um man i don't know well i guess people
would say that
i'm more the
i'm more the quiet kind of guy until you
really get to know me
and then i'm just like obnoxious like
you will
you will regret wanting to get to know
me because i'm like so obnoxious towards
them and i like i like talking a lot
um other than that um wow yeah i'm i'm a
pretty quiet dude other than that um
all right man that's something uh
people called actually we had a couple
calls that came in here good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one